hi welcome to the shore of Galliano
island where we're risking life and limb
and camera equipment to shoot poi videos
for you question came through the online
course on mastering shoulder reels and
something was saying one of their PO I
always speeds up going behind their
shoulders and doing a same time shoulder
reel
my advice is a couple of things one
piece of advice is this keep starting
from here just let the point hang and
you can even let them hit you in the
butt a bit to feel where they are so you
can start developing a feeling for where
the ploy are so from here and there
hanging is you know just where they are
and you let your hands kind of be in
contact with their shoulders so you know
where your hands are you can come out to
the right side and try to go right back
to where you were you can come to the
left side and go right back to where you
were and keep starting from them just
hanging come to this side stop to this
side stop you can even hit yourself
sometimes
and try to feel both Po and you start
knowing where the poi are when you can't
see them so if you keep doing that you
for sure will develop a feeling for
where the poi are hitting yourself will
help sometimes so after a while you'll
you'll get used to it and you'll be able
to swing through that position without
stopping and at that point you'll know
where the poor are even you can't see
them and you'll know that one's not
going faster than the other so that's
one of piece of advice for mastering
shoulder reels the other one is you know
these things just take time so sometimes
I'll show somebody a move and they'll do
it and it'll look more like that and
they'll say but it doesn't look like you
and I'll say it's because you learned it
today I've been doing this for 15 years
so sometimes it'll just take time and I
mean weeks or months four moves moves to
be really smooth they'll keep getting
better but if you compare yourself to
somebody who's been doing poi for years
and you want a move to look just like
theirs right away you'll get frustrated
so just give yourself time and you'll be
a lot happier and those are my main tips
the other one is mirrors if you can find
a mirror use a window as your reflection
at night being able to see it for sure
is gonna allow you to improve quickly or
even right now I can see my shadow on
the rocks I can use that to get the poi
flying together so those are my tips
good question
there's no clap seals clap
there are seals is also waves
[Music]